اذا هناك شريحه كبيره من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي تقرب بصعوبه الاوضاع والشواهد
على ذلك كثيره اولها الاحتجاجات المستمره
ضد الحكومه كما ذكرنا مشاريع القوانين
التي تريدها حكومه نتنياهو تثير غضب
الشارع لانها ستغير العلاقه بين الحكومه
الجهه التنفيذيه والسلطه القضائيه
سترفض الحكومه ستفرض الحكومه رايها في
تشكيل المحكمه العليا وتتقلص صلاحياتها في
الاعتراض على التشريعات التي تقرها
الاغلبيه في الكنيست النتيجه منحو نتنياهو
امكانيه الهروب من اي محاكمه قضائيه
لوقائع الفساد المتهم بها واعطائه الحق في
منح مناصب وزاريه
لمتهمين بالفساد اخرين في التحالف الحكومي
من دون اي اعتراض من السلطه القضائيه
وتجاوز احكامها السابقه بشان هؤلاء كما
حدث مع الوزير ارياد راعي التظاهرات التي
انطلقت في الشوارع الاسرائيليه ضد هذه
الخطط اظهرت مدى الانقسام الحاد في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي شهدت مشاركه متصاعده
من كبار ضباط الاحتياط مثلا هناك ضابطان
على الاستيلاء على دبابه اسرائيليه غير
مستخدمه في الجولان اللقاء عليها بيانا
رافضا للاصلاحات القضائيه ساره بها في
الطرقات ودعيا الناس الي توقيع للتوقيع
عليها التجاوب كان كبيرا حتى قبض عليهما
لكن الامر تطور من اثنين الى 700
وخمسين ضابطا من القوات الجويه والقوات
الخاصه
والاستخباراتيه واكدوا عدم حضورهم للخدمه
بدءا من يوم غد يوم الاحد اعتراضا على خطط
الحكومه التي تخرب امن الدوله
وديمقراطيتها بحسب ما قاله الانقسام الحاد
داخل الاجهزه الامنيه ظهر في تصريحات
المفوضه العام للشرطه الاسرائيليه كوبي
الشرطه غير سياسيه وستتصرف وفقا للقانون
الرساله مبطنه لوزير الامن القومي اتمار
بنكفير المتهم التورط المفرط في تعليمات
للشرطه اثناء التظاهرات
[موسيقى]
كل هذه الامور قد تقود اسرائيل لحرب اهليه
محتمله لكن تداعياتها بدات في الظهور
اقتصاديا هناك حاله هروب للاموال من
البنوك الاسرائيليه بمعدلات فاقت عشر مرات
المعدل المعتاد ولذلك جاء اجتماع وزير
الماليه مع رؤساء البنوك الذين عبروا عن
تخوفهم من مخاطر هروب الاموال وعلى مكانه
البنوك الاسرائيليه في الاسواق الخارجيه
هذه المخاطر التي يعبر عنها رؤساء البنوك
قائمه على ادله ومنها ايقاف مجموعه شركات
كبرى تعمل في المجال الالكتروني وتحويل
مليارين ومئتي مليون دولار من عملياتها
الخارجيه الى الداخل كما نقلت 50 شركه
استثماراتها الى خارج اسرائيل ومنها 37
شركه تعمل في مجال التكنولوجيا كل هذا ادى
الى تحذير الاقتصاديين من تراجع تصنيف
الائتماني لاسرائيل وتراجع الاستثمارات
الخارجيه لكن بماذا يرد وزير الماليه على
هذه المخاطر انكرها واصر على ان الاصلاحات
المنتظره سوف تتجاوز كل هذه الامور
انقسام الحاج في الوسط الاسرائيلي بين
مؤيد للتعديلات القضائيه ومعارض لها لقد
تخطى الصراع البعد السياسي ولم يعد يقتصر
فقط على معسكر اليمين واليسار في الحكومه
ان منطقه التدريجيا الى الشارع الاسرائيلي
عشرات الالاف يتظاهرون يوميا ومئات الالاف
اسبوعيا تتقدمها من نخب العسكريه والمدنيه
ورجال الاقتصاد ومصطلح حرب اهليه بات يطرح
على الطاوله لاول مره بشكل غير مسبوق منذ
اقامه اسرائيل
وتحذيرات من كبار القاده والمسؤولين
فحواها ان لم يقم نتنياهو بتهدئه الاوضاع
وايجاد حلول بديله للتعديلات القضائيه من
غير المستبعد ان تخرج الامور عن السيطره
وقد قال نحو 60% من الاسرائيليين في
استطلاعات للراي ان سيناريو نشوب حرب
اهليه بات واقعيا